this month we're to turn three years old
this has been a really strange year for
the channel because it's gotten an
incredible amount of attention I've been
at newspapers and magazines I've
received awards and met important
politicians and right now I'm sitting in
the studios at ABC having just recorded
an interview for Radio National that's
crazy I have to say that in all honesty
it's been really bizarre being at the
center of all this but being a teacher
I'm always looking for what I can learn
out of it and one of the biggest things
I've learned is that Prize winners and
people in the media they're ordinary
people I know they're ordinary
because I'm ordinary and there are
hundreds probably thousands really of
ordinary people doing prize-worthy work
all over the place without being noticed
and this prize it's not about me it's
about a highlight of the fact that hey
you know there's amazing stuff being
done by people everywhere if we open our
eyes to see it let's celebrate that just
for a second think about your day-to-day
life think about all the people you
interact with and work with each day
think about all the things they do
reliably and excellently that you never
take notice of you know the bus driver
you've got your school on time the
software engineer who designed the
algorithm that manages the traffic
lights to ensure your bus got red lights
and green lights that would keep you
safe on your way to your destination all
the teachers who prepare lessons and
design and mark assessments organize
timetables who stay back after school to
coach their touch football team so that
you can participate in a world-class
holistic education all of them are doing
work that ought to be celebrated you
know that that we ought to celebrate so
on which is both fair day what I want
you to remember is look up look around
you celebrate the people around you and
the visible work they do because the
truth is actually no one's ordinary
everyone's special